I want to go over the most common forms
of meditation how each of them work what
benefits each bring and also who each of
them are for and finally we have moving
meditation how does it work well moving
meditation is done when you are
completely focused on making some sort
of movement whether it's walking doing
chores yoga or even dancing while you
move you focus on the physical changes
and Sensations that occur for example if
you choose to practice moving meditation
while walking your focus will be on the
feeling of your feet touching the ground
and pushing off and so on what are the
benefits to this I believe that the main
benefits of moving meditation is that it
teaches you how to enter the Flow State
this is because certain movements such
as dance force you to be creative and
present at the same time who is this for
this form of meditation is great if you
have a hard time sitting still maybe you
have some health issues that prevent you
from doing so or maybe you feel too
jittery follow us for more helpful tips